we've had many MMA fighters visit here
yeah before a big bout you almost
canceled on us yes I did why you've got
a bit of a bad reputation in the MMA
community I do yeah explain okay so as I
date back to watching people that have
sat in this particular chair ma fighters
have yes yeah
just before a big bout Ronda Rousey came
mm-hmm and she got thrashed by a Mahinda
Nunez Miesha Tate also then you even
doubled up on Nick Diaz and Conor
McGregor Nate Diaz and Conor McGregor
yeah so Connor came before the first
fight and he was supposed to beat Nate
and then he lost right just after being
on I just have to being on your show
yes and then Nate came in the second
fight when he supposed to be Conor and
then he lost yes so up until yesterday
yeah I wasn't coming yeah yeah this is a
death seat what you're sitting in right
now is very dangerous and it feels hot
yeah listen you're here to break the
curse that's what you're going to do I
like challenge you are a light
heavyweight light heavyweight you're
moving up to heavyweight your opponent
this guy's bigger than you he is he's a
lot bigger than you he's taller he's got
a much longer reach yes
are you worried about that I'm not
worried about the the the height and the
size I fought big guys before and I like
challenges you know like a lot of people
my whole life I've chased the biggest
challenges and this is a big challenge
deep Amiel chah's dangerous guy I prefer
to say his name the way you did that
could you say it again I can't remember
how I contact high from the last
interview so drunk on white on white
wine fumes right now you seem to be
having the real good son I was having a
really good time and I do love her to
death
yeah I do yeah she's great but like for
example I have a very long reach and I'm
very tall but I am no threat to you at
all I'm like a just a scarecrow in the
wind as far as you're concerned it's
like a it's like a bendy straw yeah
: I don't know if I've ever felt more
safe
[Applause]
you